now let's talk about the scourge of
human trafficking human traffickers
exploit women children and men mostly
for forced labor and sex work the event
marks July 30th this day to raise
awareness of the scandal which happens
all over the world
almost half of track trafficking victims
are women men account for only about
one-fifth 23% are girls and 7% are boys
now more countries are reporting
trafficking now up from just 26 in 2009
to 65 in 2018 also victim detection is
increasing it's increased from 38
percent between increased rather 38
percent between the year 2007 and 2016
convictions went up 67 percent over the
same time period the 225,000 trafficking
victims the United Nations has
identified since 2003 are likely only a
small part of the full picture of
trafficking is just one aspect of what's
considered modern slavery in all more
than 40 million people are estimated to
be trapped in some sort of servitude a
steady job with a good salary and a
lucrative bonus that's the promise that
tempts many Indonesian men to leave
their homes and help to sea but what
they get is this footage released by the
Indonesian seafarers movement shows crew
members sleeping on the floor in the
cargo hold
looking malnourished and exhausted one
of them is rahmatullah he says he was
tricked by an Indonesian recruiting
agency trafficked to Somalia and forced
to spend nine brutal months aboard a
Chinese fishing boat manning nets and
packing fish for 18 hours a day when we
didn't catch enough fish or squid
we were beaten by the captain we were
beaten a lot I'm still traumatized by it
on board the crew claim they were given
a choice between going hungry and eating
spoiled fish and they didn't even have
clean water on the vacation we were
given fish we could tell by the smell
that the fish was already bad after
smelling it we couldn't eat it on a
daily basis all we got was cabbage and
rice with a little salt and we drank
condensation water that we collected
from the air-conditioner rahmatullah and
his crewmates are now back home and
they've taken photos and videos to
document their experience
experts say the fishing industry is
riddled with forced labor and it
predominantly targets poor workers from
Southeast Asian once on board there's no
way out for the men and they're often
mercilessly exploited rahmatullah and
his crewmates say they owed thousands of
dollars in unpaid wages
I worked far away for my family so they
could be proud of me when I returned
home but the reality was different when
I asked the recruitment company for our
rights
they said you're a stupid idiot we just
wanted to ask for our rights after
working for seven months numerous NGOs
both local and international have rung
the alarm about the slave-like
conditions that seemed to be commonplace
on fishing vessels across the globe but
it hasn't stopped men like these from
falling into the hands of traffickers
in an aegis Ministry of Manpower is
among other things tasked with a
protection of its workers abroad the
department head acknowledges the problem
but says it's difficult to monitor labor
conditions at sea with a blue flag daddy
but all we need to study first whether
the information about the abused
seafarers is true or not we must rely on
data and facts so we can enforce actions
lawfully Cantus welding and corridor
unda Munda but as rahmatullah and his
former crewmates know data and facts are
difficult to obtain when you're at sea
with no one watching